Vsauce Kevin here sailing the high seas
avast ye scurvy dogs actually I'm in a
kiddie pool and you're not scurvy dogs
because scurvy was just some weird thing
that pirates got or something or is it a
disease everyone can still get today and
as the centuries long search for its
cause and cure show us how life-saving
knowledge can be hidden right in front
of our faces
yes scurvy is a disease caused by a
deficiency of ascorbic acid commonly
known as vitamin C it's necessary for
the absorption of iron which fortifies
red blood cell production red blood
cells help carry oxygen from your lungs
to the rest of your body vitamin C is
also necessary for connective tissues
muscles tendons blood vessels bones and
the formation of collagen the glue that
binds your body together zombies could
probably benefit from vitamin C guinea
pigs are one of the only animals whose
livers don't synthesize vitamin C a
short list that includes some primates
and all humans for us it's thought to be
the result of an evolutionary defect
that occurred 60 million years ago and
it means that we have to get vitamin C
from someplace else
food here are some foods that contain
vitamin C
while fresh fruits and vegetables are
the most common sources of vitamin C for
the Inuit people living in the Arctic
there's as much vitamin C
pound-for-pound and beluga whale skin as
there is in orange juice scurvy is so
rare today that it's often overlooked by
doctors when patients do suffer from it
it takes only about ten milligrams of
vitamin C a day to stave off than eight
ketchup packets but in a world without
cheap prepackaged servings of sweet and
tangy tomato goop without foods
fortified with extra vitamin C without
any idea that vitamins even existed men
were trapped on boats for months at a
time
eating salted meat biscuits and beer a
diet with a daily recommended allowance
of vitamin C floating right around zero
percent the age of sail which lasted
from the late 15th to mid 19th century
was defined by European powers exploring
and warring over seas supremists
warships grew bigger vessels for
commerce flourished and voyages lasted
longer mortality rates at sea were so
high that some ships would leave port
with up to 50% more sailors than they
needed to try to make up for the deaths
caused by scurvy cannonballs Krakens and
Captain Hook can compare to a deficiency
of vitamin C so what happens when you
get scurvy according to the National
Health Service scurvy is characterized
by fatigue pain in the limbs swollen
gums and the appearance of red blue
spots on the skin which doesn't sound
too bad but according to a surgeon on a
16th century English voyage symptoms can
get a lot more graphic it rotted all my
gums which gave out a blackened putrid
blood my thighs and lower legs were
black and gang
I was forced to use my knife each day to
cut into the flesh in order to release
this black and foul blood I also used my
knife on my gums which were livid and
growing over my teeth had cut away this
dead flesh and caused much black blood
to flow i rinsed my mouth and teeth with
my urine rubbing them very hard
the unfortunate thing was that I could
not eat desiring more to swallow and to
chew okay let's break this down urine
which contains ammonia was used as a
mouthwash and teeth whitener for
centuries documented by 1st century BC
Roman poet Catullus
in a verse about Arrivals beautifully
polished teeth the higher the polish on
your teeth the more it proclaims that
you have drunk your piddle and cutting
out foul blood or bloodletting was a
foundational tenets of medical reasoning
from Hippocrates in 4th century BC
Greece through the 19th century despite
the Surgeon General of the East India
Company writing in 1617 and lemon juice
prevents and pure scurvy it took years
for anyone to understand why 316 years
before the rise of modern medicine
ailments were thought to be treated by
balancing the four humors blood black
bile yellow bile and phlegm the scurvy
suffering surgeon thought he had too
much blood so he performed a venesection
to release some then along came dr. lime
tree surgeon James Lind whose last name
derives from the old norse for lime tree
performed the first controlled clinical
trial in human history while aboard the
english warship hms salisbury in 1747
Lind separated scurvy afflicted sailors
into six pairs he then monitored the
effects of treating them with cider a
sulfuric acid cocktail vinegar sea water
oranges and lemons and garlic paste Lind
found that the most sudden and visible
good effects were perceived from the use
of oranges and lemons but without
knowledge of vitamins he was forced to
explain the results to the medical world
of his time he concluded that the
dampness at sea blocked perspiration
which led to an imbalance of alkalinity
basically that sailors weren't sweating
properly because they were wet all the
time and acidic fruits restored the
body's internal pH balance none of which
is remotely true but he didn't know that
no one understood the chemistry of
nutrition it was a different world with
different rules and Lind was just trying
to understand what he observed and
explained it to others
but it didn't work with no scientific
understanding of how a lemon could
prevent and cure scurvy other purported
remedies included mixing hydrochloric
acid into drinking water or drinking
wort of malt a precursor to beer
promoted as a scurvy elixir by Dublin
physician david McBride with the support
of the Royal Society wort of malt not
only contained a zero of vitamin C it
actually inhibited its absorption was
like giving a thirsty person a cup of
sand
despite scurvy killing over two million
sailors during the age of sail it wasn't
much motivation to find a cure ship
owners were more concerned about their
expensive ships sailors were easier to
replace it wasn't until the warship HMS
Gloucester had to be abandoned in 1742
because there weren't enough sailors to
continue Manning it that England put
effort into a solution ships were loaded
with lemon rob a concentrate invented by
Lind which unknowingly destroyed half
the vitamin C in the process storing the
robbed deteriorated the vitamin C
further over time but it still worked
well enough that in 1799 the Royal Navy
ordered a lemon and sugar cocktail to be
administered daily to all sailors scurvy
plummeted which gave the British Navy a
tremendous advantage in Napoleonic Wars
scurvy was cured
until it wasn't the advent of steam
engines meant shorter trips so the
importance of lemons was seen as less
critical lemons which had been planted
throughout Sicily to supply the British
Navy were eventually replaced in 1860 by
more readily available West Indies limes
they believed that acidity provided the
cure and wild lions are more acidic than
lemons they have half the vitamin C 50
years later further misunderstandings of
scurvy led Robert Falcon Scott
expedition to Antarctica to not include
any citrus at all and the trip was such
a disaster that absolute Terry Gerard
called it the worst journey in the world
but you didn't have to be a sailor or an
explorer to suffer from scurvy when baby
formula became popular in the early
1900's it contained no vitamin C and
thousands of infants died by 1920 orange
juice was mixed into the formula
ultimately the knowledge that fresh
fruits and vegetables cured and
prevented scurvy wasn't enough we needed
to understand the process that was
involved humanity required a shot in the
arm like with a bullet in 1917 in the
midst of World War one a young Hungarian
soldier named Albert sent gurgi wanted
to get back to the University of
Budapest so badly he said he was
overcome with such a mad desire to
return to science that one day I grabbed
my revolver and in my despair put a shot
through my upper arm
he finished his MD later that year
without a clue that a guinea pig would
lead him to a Nobel Prize while studying
a deficiency disorder called berry berry
researchers axel host and fedor frolic
decided to switch out their pigeon test
subjects or a mammal they faithfully
chose the non vitamin C producing guinea
pig which died from scurvy like symptoms
when fed a strict diet of brain
for the first time an animal was
observed with scurvy they honed their
experiments and by 1932 Center G had
isolated ascorbic acid prior to the
discovery of x-rays the electron
radioactivity and relativity scientific
learning was largely limited by our
senses you can see a hungry lion you
can't see its electrons you can see
rotten fruit you can't see if it has
vitamin C the constraints of medical
reasoning of the era prevented James
Lind from saving millions of lives his
knowledge was imprisoned by the
zeitgeist a German word representing the
dominant ideals and beliefs of a
particular period of time in his 1970
book the crazy 8 albert sent gurgi
described the zeitgeist as a cage
he said the freedom of human thought is
very limited we all live in a very
narrow cage the spirit of our times in
which we have very limited freedom of
motion if in different ages people
thought differently this was not because
the cage got wider but because the cage
moved
by discovering ascorbic acid and finally
solving a mystery that plagued humans
for thousands of years
Albert sent gurgi moved the cage today
we live in a cage created by the math
biology chemistry and physics of our
time and just like James Lind couldn't
conceive the chemistry of lemons and
livers we have a hard time moving our
own cage Oh Bert Sanger G included a
quote in his 1957 book bioenergetics
that says research is to see what
everybody has seen and think what nobody
has thought in order to move our cage we
have to step outside its confines and
see things from a new perspective
whether it's to advance science improve
our world or just better ourselves like
vitamin C and scurvy a solution that can
revolutionize life as we know it exists
just outside the limits of our own
kiddie pool the greatness in each of us
lies in our ability to move beyond
limitations to find a way to see what
everybody else has seen but to think
what nobody else has thought and the
fear complacency and obstacles in our
path are washed away as soon as the wall
impeding discovery is broken down and as
always
thanks for watching
hey I'm really excited to announce that
I did a collaboration with sesame
studios it's a blanket fort memory game
it's for really really little future
vsauce fans so go over there check it
out make sure you subscribe while you're
there and yeah I'll see you over there
in the blanket for it okay bye